hey everyone my name is Paul welcome to
the heavy spoiler show and I'm so
excited to talk about one of my favorite
films of all time that is alien and I
think the level of influence at its head
over the Sci-Fi genre is completely
undeniable I was lucky enough to see
this movie when I was about four years
old because my Grandad knew I like cool
space aliens and he taped it for me
after seeing the title many happy
nightmares followed and it's a film that
stuck with me for years and years and
years now throughout this video I want
to go through the films scene by scene
to talk about all the little details in
it horrifying hidden themes and just
some of the aspects that make it one of
the greatest movies ever made
[Laughter]
now this would never actually have been
made at Star Wars not been so successful
20th Century Fox had the script lying
around for a while and they weren't
expecting Lucas to deliver the massive
Blockbuster that he did people were
desperate for science fiction stories
and they quickly green lit it and
ordered a cash in on the hype what we
got is very different totally the Star
Wars like very very different but I'm so
glad that it got made now Scott actually
borrowed slightly from Star Wars and
just in the same way that we get an
opening on the Star Destroyer alien
starts off with this opening on the
Nostromo the underside of the ships are
shot in a similar way and it helps to
add skull and scale to the vessels there
are two versions of this film which
exist and depending on what you watch
you'll get a couple of extra scenes and
moments the director's cut is actually
47 seconds shorter than the theatrical
version even though it technically has
more scenes and this was achieved by
shortening some of the other sequences
and exercising certain unnecessary
moments there's a big list of the
differences online with most of them
being things like character drinking
coffee and so on and so forth Scott said
that he trimmed things down because he
wanted to keep up the pace but also
adding extra stuff so we got more of the
movie personally I prefer the theatrical
version but let me know below which one
of the two you like now there are two
big differences Alan Brett goes looking
for Jonesy he lets him water drip on him
in order to refresh him depending on
what version you watch we get a moment
in which we see some change dangling
down and amongst them you can catch the
xenomorph hidden there this adds to its
chameleon-like structure and throughout
the film the environment itself looks a
lot like the xenomorph this adds to the
subliminal horror of it and around every
corner you feel like you could run into
it now there's also an extra scene in
which we see some of the crew turning
into eggs this of course contradicts the
way they're laid in the sequel with the
alien queen being the one who's behind
it you can find this version in the
director's cut but yeah it does go
against the established law that would
end up springing up in the sequel I also
think it was removed because there's not
really anything in nature where
creatures turn into a different species
egg half their size another scene is
creepy I tend to go with a theatrical
and like I said that's across the board
too that is my favorite version with
even really Scott admitting that he only
did the director's cover money and that
he likes the one he put out originally
the best which yeah fair enough I'd won
the money and a Ridley is actually from
South Shields which is where I live and
a couple of years back they had this
great alien exhibit with all the props
costumes and so on now at its heart
aliens very much a slasher said in space
and Scott said that he actually looked
more at movies like Texas Chainsaw than
anything in the Sci-Fi genre but it does
perfectly is that it slowly builds this
feeling of dread throughout the film and
things get more and more extreme the
longer we go on there's this feeling of
an easiest that gets more and more
intense and this is set up early on with
the slow title reveal it's also the fact
that not aware is spoken in the film for
the first seven minutes and you very
much get detached from what's going on
the title itself almost feels like it's
in an alien language too as the letters
slowly fade in on first viewing we don't
fully know what the word will be and
they're almost like hieroglyphics
throwing us off balance until the name
of the film's revealed obviously we know
the movie is going to be called alien
but this slow reveal definitely has the
feeling that we don't fully understand
what's going on it's in an easy way to
start the movie and there's also large
gaps of Silence with minor drones from
the score creeping in when we do finally
get to see the crew interacting though
we get a great moment around the lunch
table in which we bond with them all the
dialogue here really helps you decide
with them and it's such a fun scene come
the end of the film we watch as this
group is torn apart and see that all of
the people within it aren't who they
seem to be who I'm talking about is of
course Ash who is revealed to be an
Android the franchise actually keeps up
a nice theme throughout and when viewed
in release order the main films all have
an Android in them whose initial sense
in alphabetical order a is for Ash and
alien B is for Bishop and aliens in
Alien 3. call appears in Alien
Resurrection and Prometheus gets at D
and David in the film we learn that Ash
is working for the company and that he's
been instructed to bring back this
xenomorph the crew is Expendable and he
doesn't mind getting his hands dirty to
get rid of them throughout the film
there are some clues that he's well
aware of what's going on and after Kane
is attacked by the face I got we catch
him watching a monitor this is him
scanning Kane's body and he'd clearly be
aware of the alien embryo inside of him
as soon as he realizes Ripley's there he
turns this off almost like he's an
embarrassed teenager when their parent
walks in the room this is to hide it
from Ripley and he knows that questions
will be raised if she sees what's going
on now the knowledge of the xenomorph is
also carried over to the chess burster
scene Ash is the only one who doesn't
initially get up to help Kane and we
even cut to a shot of him sitting whilst
the others help out Scott also said that
when the group wake up Ash actually
takes longer because he's almost like a
computer starting up and this very much
mirrors the system on the ship turning
on in the beginning now when we go to
Kane we can see Ash to the ride and you
might notice that Ian Holmes isn't
actually breathing at this point and it
isn't until much later that he starts to
do this now mother is the other bit of
artificial intelligence that we meet in
the movie she actually steers the ship
towards the signal and he's also well
aware that it's putting the crew in
danger I know people have gone back and
forth over whether this was the true
Mission or not but I think this line
about Ash actually gives it away did you
ever ship out with Ash before I went out
five times with another science officer
they replaced him two days before we
left thetas with Ash they were given the
new science officer and Ash because the
company wanted to put an Android amongst
them that would obey the true Mission
now the xenomorph itself was based on
the artwork of HR Kiko with an acronym 4
being the piece that eventually evolved
into the creature giga's work is full of
phalluses and the movie itself is sexual
and the tones to it which we'll get into
later on in the video it's very much
carrying the idea of male pregnancy
through assault smothering and so on and
so forth now in addition to phallic
imagery we also get a lot of things that
look like the JJ's you know what I mean
mate can't say what it is because
YouTube's doing stupid [__]
demonetization on anything slightly
controversial anyway the Facehugger
possesses this in their design and the
original Alien X themselves also had it
too Scott realized he'd probably get an
x-raying if he went through with what
Kika wanted though and thus they turn
into opening almost like flower petals
now there's very much this idea of the
sleeping chamber being like a womb 2 and
with the ship's Captain being mother we
have this all time together early on we
get a tour of the Nostromo and we can
see that most of the shapes and
structures are made up of tubes and
openings when crafting the design Giga
said that he wanted to create something
biomechanical and this this idea
throughout the machines in Alien are a
mix of things you'd see in both man-made
and natural beings we get the computer
intercepting the distress call and then
the crew wake up almost like they're
opening their eyes for the first time
after being born the pods are in a
cylindrical shapes and the crew coming
out of them is meant to be similar to
the way an animal hatches out of an egg
eggs of course play a major part in the
film and in the opening we see lots of
things that are related to them at one
point we catch two nodding birds and
then later as we go into the main
section we see three egg models
vibrating up and down this is the
chicken coming before the egg which
might be a rich now the way the papers
flap around in such gives the idea that
there's very much something moving
through the ship watching over what's
going on we don't know what this is but
it's very much meant to be voyeuristic
from here we cut into the sleeping
quarters and watch the crew you very
much being born birth is a theme in the
movie too with the alien being born out
of Kane who just so happens to be the
first character we're introduced to we
are supposed to believe that he is the
main person that we should be following
and for this initial act he very much is
he's the one we focus on here the most
and he's the one who leads everyone into
the space jockey ship thus when he dies
it's a major twist in the movie's
dynamics that plants the idea No One Is
Safe Dallas is also painted as one of
the main characters too and it's a long
time before we focus on Ripley now
Ripley originally was a man in the
script and interestingly Scott didn't
end up changing any of the lines to fit
the gender swap if we're sticking with
the confines of a slasher movie then
Ripley is very much the Final Girl
archetype who navigates the movie by
sticking to the rules she refuses to let
Kanan when he's infected and very much
goes by the book on a lot of the issues
now we cut to them all eating around the
table and we can catch Jones the cat
there too in the film all of the
characters are referred to by their last
name due to being the best way to
address them professionally and this is
even the case with the cat too Jones is
very much seen as a member of the crew
as well and the animal is of course
there to boost morale if you pay close
attention to the scene you might also
catch Ash reaching out and grabbing a
jug of milk which is something and he
continues to drink throughout the movie
later on when he's revealed to be an
Android we see he has a milky substance
instead of blood and this could be
what's sustaining his synthetic body a
shout out to the now playing podcast for
saying that the entire crew are very
much meant to be space truckers and in
the 70s convoys and such were all the
rage it adds his extra human element to
them and we relate to them more because
they just come across as Everyday People
now he watches Dallas goes the mother
which is a giant room of blinking lights
and buttons though I've been talking
about sexual organs a lot there are body
parts laced throughout the designs of
everything and mother is very much
supposed to be a brain from here we go
back to the crew and see them working at
their stations at lamb bets we see a box
with Balaji Imperial written on it and
this is actually a brand of cigarettes
it's solely for the movie later on we
see Ripley's computer and you can catch
a picture of Jonesy's a little kitten
which is not it's nice isn't it I don't
know I'm actually a dog person anyway
Jonesy was actually portrayed by four
different cats with one being used for
holding the other for hissing and the
other two for running off Lambert also
mentions and astromo is close to Zeta to
ratculi which is an actual star system
that's one of the closest to her own the
name Nostromo comes from the title of
the 1904 Joseph Conrad novel which
follows an Italian explorer who tries to
plunder a silver mine the nostrama is
also a mining vessel in the film hence
why that name ended up being used and
the crew end up traveling to lb46 and we
see all the procedures that they have to
go through in order to land the shuttle
air when discussing the movie The
screenwriters stated that they were so
happy Scott actually put as much effort
as he did into this scene as it shows
how difficult it is to actually land on
another planet whereas a lot of sci-fi
movie shows being as simple as driving a
car we see just how difficult it is here
Star Wars wipes have become a thing
where we just watch a planet being
approached and then skip all this but I
appreciate that they put all this effort
into what could be a throwaway scene the
environment here is extremely hostile
and three members of the crew end up
heading out into it in spacesuits these
were apparently a nightmare to film in
and in between takes the helmets had to
be constantly taken off to them filling
up with carbon dioxide Ridley Scott
actually used some of his own children
for a lot of the scenes in the suits and
this was in order to make the scale and
size of the areas look larger as they
approached the ship you also see several
things that pull from the human body and
the two doors that the crew go up into
look like the JJ's again sorry ladies
and inside the walls also appear like
rib cages now as canis ends into the
ship we see the back of his helmet which
has been purposely designed to look
similar to the alien's body there's
tubes protruding out of the back of it
and these also look exactly like its
tail now there's a skeletal feeling to
the entire surrounding with his ship's
pile of very much seeming like an
extension of the chair you can't really
see where it ends and where it begins
making for a really eerie scene a
screenwriter Daniel O'Bannon went over
what was originally supposed to be in
the space jockey scene and there were
some things that he ended up explaining
though Prometheus shows the series being
how the space jockey Pilots the ship it
was originally intended to be where the
SOS Beacon was sent out from the team
would then arrived there and turned the
beacon off and during this moment they
notice a triangle on the machine they
then exit the ship and come across a
giant pyramid which is where the Alien X
were originally stored like them the
space jockey and his crew adventured
down to the planet searching for
something and it's here where they went
through something similar to what
happened with the crew of the Nostromo
and fox actually wanted to originally
cut the space jockey due to the budget
but Scott insisted that it was left in
they of course went on to make two
Prometheus movies and without Scott's
persistence they never would have
happened personally I I wish that it had
just remained a mystery and like the
thing prequel I think the imagination of
what the ship is is way more interesting
than than what we could have gotten
especially when it's things like they
designed the entire human race which
moving on now the creature being
Incorporated in the budget is something
I'm so glad Scott got to do however he
did concede that the pyramid was gonna
be way too expensive thus they just put
the eggs in the ship and they lie within
the bowels of it as Kane carries out his
descent he watches the walls once more
act like a rib cage and it's almost as
if Kane is descending into the nine
circles of hell now upon approaching the
eggs we can see that there's a laser
light almost acting like a barrier that
warns people not to cross it you might
notice that his Cane moves his hand
through it The Sound gets more and more
high-pitched the closer that he gets
just covering the eggs that react when
broken
now this is such a cool thing in the
film but originally it wasn't supposed
to be there the creative team actually
wanted to have webbing blocking the way
but they realized how difficult that was
gonna be to produce they actually ended
up going into the next lot and here they
came across the who who were rehearsing
for a concert they borrowed one of their
lasers for the show along with some dry
ice and that's how we got the effect now
the eggs in the face are some of the
most memorable things about this movie
and they use dead animal entrails for
both the Facehugger was made up of a
shellfish and the stink of it got so bad
on set that the casting crew were
apparently vomiting after getting close
to it I went crafting the script Ron
shushid said that one of the big
problems they faced was how they
actually got the alien off the planet
and onto the ship they needed to do it
in a way that didn't make the crew look
like idiots and they realized that the
only way to do it and I quote was have
the alien [__] someone now they actually
do something that messes with your head
a bit and when Kane approaches it we can
see moisture droplets on the top
dripping upwards Against Gravity this is
to disorientate us and make us get the
feeling that we don't quite understand
the surroundings the top of the egg then
opens up and Kane decides to do the
scientific thing and stick his face
directly in it the name of science I
will put my base in it it all happened
so fast and I love how Scott takes his
time actually showing what's happened to
Kane we see the crew come back to the
ship which is difficult to make out and
even the airlock is covered in smoke
with a focus on Dallas and Lambert
instead of Kane after the helmet is
removed we see this spider-like creature
wrapped around Kane's face the tendrils
are designed to look like fingers with
it almost crushing Kane's head another
point they're now playing brought up
which I think is really important is
that typically in movies if something
bleeds we tend to see as being a
weakness
streets we can kill it this isn't the
case with these creatures though and
even their blood is a defense mechanism
we see that the creature spouts acids
from its wounds and this is strong
enough to melt through the hull of the
ship
it's got a wonderful defense mechanism
you don't dare kill it conceptual artist
Ron Cobb came up with the idea for this
because they ran into your problem with
the third act in which they knew
audiences would ask why they just didn't
shoot it so this was a workaround and it
made it so that every attack on the
creature could cause more damage to the
crew and ship we then get more bias
shots and come across Ash clearly
looking at the embryo inside Kane as
mentioned earlier he turns us off when
Ripley comes over and originally in the
script she was gonna ask what the black
mass in his lungs was but I think this
would have given the game away as to
what could be coming on the first
viewing we're supposed to believe the
titular alien is the Facehugger and this
question that there's something else
might ruin the dinner surprise but that
she does ask the right questions here
and it gives the game away with Ash a
bit
you also forgot the science division's
basic quarantine law
that I didn't forget oh I see you just
broke it unfortunately by breaking
quarantine you risk everybody's life
maybe I shouldn't have left him outside
maybe I've jeopardized the rest of us
but it was the risk I was willing to
take
a big risk
or a science officer
not exactly out of the manual is it
now Ripley wanted to quarantine the
group and if he was truly a man of signs
he'd understand why that's so important
but instead he went against protocol and
this tips his hand a bit that he wanted
the creature on the ship he once again
drinks milk and we cut to Dallas
learning that the creature is now of
Cain while the film is brilliantly here
is that it actually lures you into a
false sense of security we had the crew
looking for the creature and the little
jump scare when the corpse of the face
like a lantern Ripley's shoulders we are
supposed to think that the alien is dead
and Kane waking up in good spirits makes
us begin to relax as an audience I love
the line about him having a nightmare
about smothering and he's very much
repressed this trauma again this carries
the themes of assault and people very
much hiding the memory from themselves
because of the horror that it carries
Stella O'Kane moves on and we get the
dinner scene which is once more put in
place to make us relax it mirrors that
first scene we've already sort of been
through something similar and we know
that nothing bad can happen however it's
at this point that we're treated to one
of the most memorable scenes of all time
in which the alien makes a a big
entrance now one of the myths about this
movie is that none of the cast and crew
knew this was going to happen and that
it was all a surprise that's not
strictly true as they of course had this
script what they didn't know though is
that they'd be sprayed with fake blood
so that's very real and it's why
Veronica Cartwright looks so caught off
God if you listen to the score here it's
also like a heartbeat thumbing away as
we see the horror play out now Parker
goes to snap out the creature but Ash is
the one who says not to touch it which
spares it from being killed on a second
watch this is very much him playing his
hand and I love going back through the
movie and spotting these little moments
now the alien looks a bit goofy now but
I honestly find this little xenomorph a
bit cute and it's funny watching it
skate off like a remote control car Also
earlier in the scene we can catch in Mr
Fusion at the table and this would later
pop up in Back to the Future as a prop
from the film anyway Kane's funeral is
Swift and almost emotionless adding to
the sterile and solitary feeling that
one would likely experience when moving
through space whereas in most horror
movies we see as people we follow low
attempt to get away from the killer who
watches the crew instead go on the hunt
so far all I've experienced the small
creatures like the young xenomorph and
Facehugger and thus they believe that
they can kill it with ease we get the
old animal fake out scene which at the
time wasn't really a cliche and it wants
more Lewis us into a false sense of
security also worth pointing out that
Chevy Chase actually wore the same cap
that Brett does in Fletch so a bit of
trivia and the thumbs up buttons right
there now Brett comes across some skin
which in hindsight we know is due to the
creature shedding he goes off into one
of the ventilation rooms and if you look
at the recess on the four main
structures you can see that several of
them look like the aliens head and tail
as he lets water drip on his face we can
actually also hear the faint hits of
this anymore of hanging just above him
foreign
then drops down and attacks before
taking bread away we then get a quick
hit of Jonesy as the cat watches things
playing out this is a technique that
Scott would use in Blade Runner and we
cut to tyrells out as his murder played
out Blade Runner actually reuses several
Graphics from this film including many
things that we see on computer screens
and the tongue with the tongue gives a
morphallic imagery and it very much has
to penetrate its prey to stun them now
from here we go to Ripley and Parker
saying that the alien took bread up into
the air shaft but how they know never
gets fully explained in a theatrical cut
oh we're in the director's cut we see
they run in and get covered in blood as
they look up at this point Ash refers to
the creature as Kane's son this little
[__] is huge
I mean it's like a man it's big okay and
son
it's such a creepy time to talk about
the creatures being Cain's son and it
shows he's more sympathetic towards it
than the rest of the crew normally you
you wouldn't refer to a monster like
this as being someone's Offspring but he
does it because he has a different
appreciation for it than the rest of the
crew does now this whole airlock scene
is another standout moment in the film
that pretty much defined the genre I
remember a couple of years ago I was
really excited for alien isolation
because it was recapturing the look and
feel of this film however IGN they gave
it a 5.9 out of 10 and I decided not to
get it which I'll never forget I will
never forget mate anyway it went on sale
a couple of years later and I picked it
up and I was blown away by the game igen
were wrong hashtag never listen to IGN
and the reason why I'm talking about it
here is because there's actually DLC for
it involving the Nostromo crew and in
that you have to crawl through the vents
like what we see here it's just as tense
playing as it is to watch and if you're
a fan of horror games in this film then
you'd definitely have to pick it up and
what makes the scenes so tense is that
we spend a lot of it in darkness with
only Dallas's light to show us the way
again we have images of body parts with
the closing shutters being like a
butthole look I Never Promised the
breakdown would be high bro yeah you can
also see them as an iris I suppose with
them opening and closing and the horror
here is so simple and Scott uses sound
perfectly to create a terrifying
atmosphere I'm sure now playing
mentioned that the motion tracker was
made by using a football game on an
Atari 2600 but whatever it is the
Simplicity is what gives the scene its
Terror rather than being a 3D map it's
just two dots moving across the screen
with the beeps mimicking our heart rate
as the creature gets closer in most
confrontations like this when two dots
line up you'd expect there to be a big
jump scare or something but in this
movie nothing actually happens this
throws the audience in Dallas completely
off guard because we now know that the
creature is close by we still can't see
it though and thus your mind starts to
wonder and the crew are terrified for
him well all except for ash who once
more calmly observes it because he wants
to see what will happen after he's taken
Ripley has given his privileges as she's
the next in line for command Lambert
wants to take her chances in the shuttle
and as we see this ends up becoming the
plan later on anyway at this point they
want to push it into the airlock and
blast it into space and originally there
was a scene along these lines involving
Ash that also played his hand the
deleted scene had the creature just
about to go under the airlock and the
crew watched over on monitors just
before it stepped through Ash sounded
the alarm and it startled as anymore of
which then fled things would have given
the game away far too early and I can
definitely see why they ended up
removing it instead Ripley says Ash
[Music]
any suggestions from you or mother
no we're still collating
you what
what you're still collating
I find that hard to believe
I've got access to mother now and I'll
get my own answers thank you this is Ash
once more lying and thus Ripley goes
directly to Mother upon learning the
truth Ash appears and we get one of the
most graphic scenes in the film if you
go off the subtext now when discussing
the scene on the commentary Ridley Scott
said that this is very much a metaphor
for sexual assault with Ash shoving a
literal adult magazine down her throat
and also the audiences upon explaining
it he said that being an Android meant
that Ash didn't have the parts that men
do and thus he'd build up frustration
over the voyage this was him very much
assaulting Ripley and the only way he
could the director said that Ash didn't
actually want to kill her in this moment
it's something I never considered at all
when watching the movie and I don't
really like to think about that kind of
stuff but I do think the directors
intentions are important to talk about
Ash spraying white fluid everywhere
could be seen as well you know and this
leads to the big reveal that he's a
robot coming with his head being smashed
like it's the like button it's also
important to bear in mind that Ripley
has a nosebleed here and she actually
ends up getting one in every film from
here to Resurrection and they put his
head on the table and unfortunately
they're leaving one of the worst Chum
cuts ever as we switch from the dummy to
Ian home I think on the whole at the
effects in this film really hold it more
than 40 years later but I really wish
they just cut back to the crew and then
to the switched our head instead of
keeping it in the shot Scott even said
that he hated this effect and said that
the mold for ash actually ended up
getting deformed due to conditions on
set this left it looking slightly
different on how home does and yeah it's
not the finest moment in the film but
they did win the Oscar for best special
effects so we'll let you off there mate
either way I'm nitpicking and I think
the fact that Ash is in Android is the
best twist in the film as it adds
another enemy for the crew to have to
work around unlike the alien Ash can
talk in a moat and we hear about how he
admires the creature they are very
similar to one another in many respects
as they both work for something bigger
than them and will kill those that get
in the way of that goal they also
operate Basin instincts and programming
that they don't fully understand now Ash
drops the chilling line
piercing and after he's burned the crew
decided to take their chances in the
shuttle there's only one life support
chamber and limited oxygen and food but
their odds are better there than they
are on the ship they split off with
Lambert and Parker going off on their
own and I love how they use the piping
and environments here to further evoke
images of the xenomorph Ripley ends up
returning to the ship after realizing
Jones is there but the xenomorph attacks
Parker and Lambert as they collect their
supplies they have such an effective use
of Shadow here with the xenomorph
closing in and you might notice some
little continuity errors here as we
watch the tale going up Lambert's
trouser leg we can also see that her
pants are navy blue here even though in
the previous shot they're white this is
because this moment actually came from
earlier in the movie and this is a scene
from when Brett was grabbed Lambert's
original death was going to involve her
hiding in a locker and she'd then die of
fried as the xenomorph moved around
outside I think the switch here was done
because of the sexual connotations that
come with it but they also had to be
mindful of how the suit looked in motion
abalaji Bodega was hired by Scott after
he saw him in a pub and standing at six
foot and 10 inches meant that he was
perfect for the role however in motion
they realized that the suit looked
pretty bad and this is why a lot of the
shots in the film are of it standing
still you do get a moment where it moves
like a ballet but the creature was cut
around due to how effective the suit
looked in Motion in better lighting and
in Alien Isolation we can also see that
the creature has a skull and eye sockets
within its head but it's difficult to
make out in the film itself now Ripley
ends up arming the self-destruct
sequence on the ship now we get a scene
in which he goes to the shuttle and then
returns here to try and disarm it this
doesn't work and thus she has to make
her way past the alien this part of the
film was also recreated in the early in
isolation DLC leading to one of my
favorite parts of the game again as she
moves through the environment we see as
certain panels in wall textures are put
in place to mimic the alien but Ripley
eventually manages to make it through
now we discovered that the xenomorph is
on board the shuttle and the set was
actually built around Balaji in order to
create this effect leaving it proved
difficult though and the suit tore in
multiple places a Ripley starts to sing
Lucky Star and this was something at
Sigourney Weaver just improvised on the
day the song pulls from singing in the
rain and unfortunately it added more
money to the budget as the studio had to
secure the licensing rights which no one
was really happy about in the end though
Ripley opens the airlock and she shoots
it with a Harpoon Gun which gets stuck
in the door as it closes and a nice bit
of attention to detail this gun can
actually be seen at the start of aliens
at the same place that it was at the end
of this film a time back to the themes
of birth This Moment's been interpreted
as a baby being pulled out of the womb
with the wire acting like an umbilical
cord finally the aliens cut free once
Ripley blasts the engines and it sends
it off into space I love how we can see
that it's still moving and it shows just
how difficult it is to kill you can't
end it you can only get rid of it and we
close out the movie with a shot of
Ripley sleeping mirroring the crew
waking up at the start this would later
be repeated in aliens with Ripley and
Newt closing out both films on positive
note and that ends the movie I hope
you've enjoyed this breakdown through
this classic film and if you have we'd
love to see at the channel again make
sure you subscribe and on screen right
now we have another classic movie
breakdown for you to watch next without
the way I've been your host Paul and I
hope to see you next time take care
peace